okay
hello hello
[Music]
[Music]
hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba John
Humphrey is my name we are going to talk
about a movie that we unfortunately did
not get the chance to do a full movie
review for at the time it came out in
the theaters but Universal Home
Entertainment has contacted us as they
wanted us to tell you guys about a film
that is getting a release on June 12th
on blu-ray DVD and digital that is for
The Strangers prey at night and in
exchange for this
they are hooking up something really
cool for us like oh yeah if anyone has
seen the first strangers or even the
trailers from strangers prey at night
but you don't like this we haven't gonna
not open the box yet and this is the
main reason we are here today before we
open this box so I want to say about the
strange prey at night if you guys
haven't seen strangers prey at night the
plot description basically goes like
this and when I say it goes like this
I'm reading word-for-word what it's
about
a family's roadtrip takes a dangerous
term and they arrive at a secluded
mobile home part to stay with relatives
and find it mysteriously deserted under
the cover of darkness three masked
psychopaths pay them a visit to test the
families every limit as they struggle to
survive so that's the plot of the movie
what I'll tell you guys is this there's
some really good acting in this film and
the film is very much a homage to 80s
horror film so I know we all love our
80s installs right now it's a Carpenter
fan like a good synth score if you like
you know a good lean mean slasher with
those sensibilities of the first one
crashed into that 80s vibe you know
you're probably gonna dig this I'm gonna
go out on a limb here and say that I've
seen a lot of horror movies that are
brand-new this year in 2018 this has one
of the best scenes in any horror movie
I've seen all year and that is the scene
at the pool if you guys have seen the
movie is it takes place where there's a
pool and there's one specific scene
[Music]
it is honestly one of the best scenes
I've seen in any horror movie this year
it's worth watching just to experience
that moment and coming from the director
of 47 meters down I mean it's cool to
see him we utilize the water for such
horrific effect you know I say we open
what's in the box that's how we do it no
but it's a slasher knife but it makes
more sense
no thing I've thought about the pocket
knife that would have made this easier
according to Joe Blow calm it is a scary
blast of tension and chills
hey Jimmy Oh before we take this off we
have to pop every one of these just get
[Music]
ready guys okay before we look greatly
at the special things this is an
unboxing video by the way forgot to
mention yeah what's in here uh uh uh not
only do we each get a his and his copy
of the movie strangers prey at night we
also got a copy of this nifty soundtrack
track is one of the best parts of the
film and I had Johnston oh they got some
cool bonus features on here oh they got
the prep for night music video the
director's cut referencing video and a
look inside the strangers praying night
that's where they have the cast and the
director talk about their experience
with the film and the family fights back
segment where there they review the film
experience yeah this is the music of the
strangers Pratt and I where they talk
about the inspired score from like John
Carpenter themes and with that other
thing they have here and alternate
ending all case you wanted to see
something a little bit different
probably something a little bit more
massive well we got this one the
underrated and theatrical cut come in
here that's awesome but John let's just
take off the plastic here oh this is so
all right I didn't even know they were
throwing in the DVDs and the CD I just
wanted to yeah I just wanted the masks
they surprised us you never get to see
who's under the masks well now you know
it's Greg and John from the real rejects
hey that we do our face reveal here in
Reverse got to do that head tilt thing
[Music]
well guys I think you know what John and
I are gonna be for Halloween this year
because we finally have a costume I
haven't had one in years so thank you to
the universal home entertainment team
strangers print and I get your own copy
on blu-ray or DVD digital June 12 you go
check out the soundtrack to San track
stays with me
John you already own a billion CDs okay
just let me get my CD player my car
fixed and then we'll be good yep but
this is the main reason why oh yeah cuz
these mats are awesome and always wonder
one since I saw the first Rangers movie
yeah I'm gonna stand across the room
from you while you're sleeping each
night you know kind of stare Femina
alright guys well the strange is prayer
night blu-ray DVD and digital comes out
on John's birthday June 12th that is the
right day for this movie to come out
happy birthday to me
oh my girlfriend is going to love me
wearing this
that's roleplay you can take to the bank
role play I mean finally ending that
damn relationship
[Music]
the strangers on Kudrow May 22nd on
blu-ray and DVD June trough